[Music]
welcome to session 42 starting year 5 of
the worlds of speculative fiction series
this time we're taking up Mary Shelley
and I thought we'd focus on novels that
have to do with with utopian and and
anti utopian ideas and the idea of
progress and decline so I picked out of
all of her stuff Frankenstein and the
last man and only after actually reading
the last man all the way through waiting
and waiting and waiting for it to get
better did I discover that there are
good reasons why so few people read the
last man kept hand in the press when it
came out but it is kind of an
interesting thing nonetheless of course
you know she's best known for
Frankenstein I think that a lot of
people saw her as the literary
equivalent of what we nowadays call a
one-hit wonder and music because of that
so what we usually do in these talks
besides having a lot of discussion and
dialogue about ideas is go over the
biography and the literary works or the
person how they fit in together and we
talk a lot about world building but with
her as with with Bram Stoker and a few
of the other people that we've looked at
I don't think we can really say that
there's effectively a world that's
that's built she's writing in the world
that more or less the world that she
lives in with the short stories it's
it's you could say much more imaginary
landscapes I suppose you could say the
same about the last man where things are
kind of idealized it's supposed to be
happening
the last man is supposed to be happening
you know almost a millennia millenium in
the future but Greece and Turkey are
still at war so you know how different
is it really
the country names are all more or less
the same and you do about the same stuff
so I don't know that we'll talk too much
about world building but I think we can
talk about world revealing with with
what goes on in her her works and in her
life and all of that so the themes that
I'd picked out I always have some
philosophical themes that I think are
particularly important you know the big
elephant in the room is the
Frankenstein's monster creating new life
what sort of responsibilities do we bear
towards it so I think there's a lot of
implications for that in terms of what
we do with animals what we do with with
human beings and cloning and genetics
and especially what we do with
artificial intelligence and then there's
there's a corresponding theme of a new
stronger race that would come about you
know the monster wants a bride in this
and probably rightly so but but
Frankenstein thinks that's a bad idea
another key thing that I think you see
running through this and we'll talk
about why it's so central to her ideas I
think it comes a lot out of her
biography is sort of a the contrast
between a new era of progress and old
ways that are holding it back where
you've got enlightenment and revolution
and romanticism on one side and then
monarchy old-fashioned class
distinctions slavery warfare tradition
and institutions on the other side and
it closely related to that something
that called the imperfection of the
perfectible as a theme so you know Mary
Shelley is the daughter of William
Godwin and Mary Wollstonecraft both of
whom
that human human progress not only
should continue but but could pretty
much indefinitely continue things could
get better and better and better and and
Shelley she's a bit more skeptical of
that even even as a you know essentially
a teenager writing writing Frankenstein
so you know she belongs to a different
generation and I think that fits in
there and then another key thing that I
I thought was an interesting theme that
hasn't been talked about that much
except among feminist critics is the
role that anger as an emotion plays in
in this work but also in other works and
so we'll probably talk a bit about the
dynamic of anger how anger functions and
why it's it's so central to making the
plot the plot because so many points for
example in Frankenstein there's so many
points where things could have worked
out and they don't because somebody is
angry at somebody else
filled with rage you know and so
estrangement and alienation is produced
by anger but I think that again
that's very reflective of her biography
so so we should look at we should look
at her or you know her life and I have
created this this timeline that doesn't
actually have a lot of writings in it in
terms of novels does he have some some
other things in it you know travelogues
and and she did also do a lot of
biographical right
so you know she's she's born in in the
very end of the 18th century to to
philosophers Mary Wollstonecraft who by
that time was known not just in England
but but I would say you know she was
growing and reputation in Europe for her
vindication of the rights of women as a
matter of fact when Godwin publishes his
ill-advised tell-all biography of her he
calls it the something like the memoirs
of the or the the
biography or something of the author of
the vindication of the rights of women
so unfortunately you know and this is
one of those things where you know you
think about how would how would history
at least literary history how would it
have been different had Mary
Wollstonecraft survived the birth of her
second child we'll talk about Fanny her
her first child and in a bit let's say
she'd actually survived because she dies
you know if not immediately in
childbirth but I think about nine days
later of complications what if she had
actually been there to to bring up young
Mary in the way that that she had wanted
a young girl to receive what she called
an education and to you know have a
mother's affection I think things would
have been quite different as it stood
you've got Godwin who is really you know
he's an interesting figure in his own
right and I say interesting in the
euphemistic sense that he's kind of a
messed up character you know he he he
writes some interesting things he is a
philosopher in the broad sense he wants
to bring about
social progress he's one of the early
utilitarians he's also one of the early
people to formulate consistent anarchism
he you know he meets Wollstonecraft
originally at a literary that that's put
on to celebrate Thomas Paine's
publication of the rights of men in
London and Mary Wollstonecraft
essentially harangues him all night long
and he is a very disagreeable
remembrance of that but that and falls
in love with her after she writes her
her travelogue about travels in
Scandinavia and then they get together
and she gets pregnant and they decide
that in order to afford the child some
social legitimacy they'll get married
and then and then she dies so they don't
get to spend that much time together and
God when it is now stock running a
household that he seems not very well
suited for for doing he's also got Mary
Wollstonecraft's other daughter too who
at that times a toddler
Fanny Emily born illegitimately to marry
in France so in 1798
Godwin manages to destroy pretty much
all of the goodwill that Mary
Wollstonecraft had built up by
publishing his biography of Mary
Wollstonecraft against the advice of all
of his friends who say you know if you
reveal this sort of thing you're going
to destroy her reputation and you're
even going to make things difficult for
yourself and he poo-poos them and does
it and sure enough that's that's exactly
what happens because you know it's
revealed that Mary Wollstonecraft had
attempted to commit suicide twice and
had the illegitimate daughter so you
know it's not Victorian age but that was
still scandalous at the time right and
then you know when Mary Shelley is only
three Godwin travels to Ireland and
leaves us
honors in the care of this guy James
Marshall that year after that he returns
and he decides that he needs another
wife to help them out in running the
household and he marries this neighbor
Mary Jane Clermont who most of his
friends dislike I think that she's very
vulgar and coarse lady and she ought she
already has a kid too from actually yeah
yeah I think she had she had one or two
kids from from her previous marriage one
of them was going to become friends with
with Mary and you know Mary and her
don't get along from the beginning Fanny
adjusts herself to dealing with this
this woman but Mary never gets along
with her stepmother
eventually the Godwin's finding
themselves deeper and deeper into debt
start a shop and publishing house called
the juvenile library publishing stories
for kids that was quite popular at the
time and Mary herself
18:12 she sent in the middle of the
Napoleonic Wars to live in the household
of this guy William Baxter and Scotland
with his four daughters and she really
likes it there he is a philosophical
radical and so her dad and this guy get
along quite well and then in 1814 she
meets Percy Shelley who's older than her
married and kind of a you know kind of a
bad guy when it comes down to it when
you think about it and he starts
visiting the Godwin household pretty
regularly Godwin is still as he is
chronically in debt and Shelley has
plenty of money so Shelley offers to
help him out and
Mary and Percy fall in love and she
loses her virginity to him according to
you no legend on the grave of her mother
quite quite probable because it was a
easy place to get away to and then she
and her stepsister Clare who had been
sort of the favored child because Clare
was was you know her stepmothers actual
daughter they leave for Europe with
Percy leaving his pregnant wife behind
so you know by this time everything's
been thrown to the wind and actually we
do take a little pause there so William
Godwin he didn't like any of this but he
didn't really have that much to complain
about because he had been attacking the
institution of marriage pretty
consistently and so then you know when
his own daughter decides that you know
free love is where it's at and you
should follow your heart and it doesn't
matter these these sort of institutional
norms and requirements and stuff like
that it's I guess it shouldn't be much
of a surprise you know
it's sort of like that old onion joke
where Eminem discovers that you know
there's a young guy who wants to date
his daughter because now his daughters
old enough when that the guy takes his
cues from Eminem's lyrics you know yes I
don't he doesn't like it so much anymore
right so you know there's there's quite
a bit of that and you know it's it's
it's also unclear whether it was just
Mary being involved with Percy Shelley
or whether it was Mary and Claire at
different times clearly you know the
Mary is enamored with him so they leave
for Europe and then when they come back
they discover that they've been cut off
by I William God
their father and you know they're
destitute Percy glacially is essentially
ran out of his money she manages well
they managed to get her pregnant
and she has she gives birth prematurely
the baby dies it's a daughter and that
begins some of her later depression as
well but then their finances begin to
improve mainly due to his family and
then Mary gives birth to their son
William who again isn't going to live
that all that long unfortunately the
couple spends a summer with Lord Byron
with Claire Clairmont or her sister and
John William Polidori and they this is
where the Frankenstein thing comes from
right there they're talking about ghost
stories everyone's supposed to come up
with one for a number of days Mary can't
come up with one and says that she feels
very embarrassed because you know she
should be a good writer and fertile and
imagination and intellect you know
living up to her her brilliant mother so
then she she comes up with a core for
this and supposedly it comes out of a
dream that she has and she she begins
working on the idea and a lot of other
things happen in that year as well her
half-brother Charles leaves for France
her half sister Fanny ends up committing
suicide
as does Percy's wife and you know Fanny
was kind of a tragic character she's
she's older than Mary and they were
close but Fanny got tasked with a lot of
the the household management stuff and
she was always you know and you could
say in terms of her her ideas she was
more conservative
then the rest of that that lot
she thought that class distinctions did
matter and you should pay attention to
that but you know she's you could see
her because kind of like a soul just
adrift her dad William well her step
stepfather William Godwin sort of threw
a lot on her shoulders didn't view her
as being as intelligent as Mary didn't
you know can compared her unfavorably
with Claire as not being as pretty as
Claire and you know you could see her
trying to do her best and a lot of the
hostility and anger that was produced
because of Mary and Claire leaving fell
on to to Fanny and so eventually she she
does kill herself to the Walkman
I think Percy's wife drowned herself
that opens up the door for Percy Shelley
and Mary to to get married which then
produces a reconciliation of the family
so you know now things are back at not
an even keel after all this tragedy
things aren't going completely great
their daughter Clara is born Mary
finishes Frankenstein begins editing
Percy's works but Percy is living away
from home a lot of the time to avoid
creditors you know it's kind of
interesting there's a lot of that at
that time really that entire like the
the 19th century and the 18th century a
lot of the literature is like people
were moving from one place to another to
avoid their creditors because your
creditors could generally only find you
at home you know so that was a way to
stay out of it and then the entire group
relocates to italy by this time claire
has gotten involved with with
hyerin and she's pregnant and gives
birth to a daughter Alba and Alba gets
handed over to Byron and she won't live
that long either most of these children
died quite young Alba is handed over to
Byron with the proviso that Claire will
have almost no interaction with her
daughter and then Byron eventually
places her in a convent where she gets
sick and dies
and Claire hate Claire hates or Claire
hates Byron to the end of her life she
looks quite a bit longer to 1819
their son William dies Mary sinks into a
depression the only thing that brings
her out is the birth of their one son
who does survive Percy Florence and she
begins writing another some people think
autobiographical novel Matilda which
doesn't get very bread anymore either
18:22 Miriam is carries and almost dies
Percy is is the one who according to the
doctors saved her by placing her into
ice but he also starts roaming around
and he spends a lot of time with this
woman Jane Williams who Mary may have
been attracted to as well and not that
long after all of that Percy and several
other people died in a boating accident
he dies of drowning they cremate him and
then Mary relocates to this household of
Leigh hunt and in Genoa and she wants to
read a biography a memoir of her husband
the big love of her life
Percy Blythe Shelly
by spice no sorry and his father
prevents it and it's kind of an
interesting side story you know she runs
throughout the rest of her work she's
always trying to find some way to make
this happen and you know this is
actually something good to pause on and
talk a bit about why would the why would
his dad be so dead set against having a
public account of his kind of crazy son
because it would destroy the family name
I mean it's not like anybody didn't know
what what the Sun was up to maybe it
would make it too public but he puts his
foot down you can't you may not you know
write this sort of thing and he makes
like having a he uses the purse strings
to control that you know you have an
allowance provided you don't you don't
write anything like that and she you
know she gets around it in certain ways
eventually she returns to England and
she you know she negotiates an allowance
for Percy Florence from from her
husband's father second edition of
Frankenstein comes out this the first
edition of Frankenstein is anonymous
second edition bears her name there's
there's you know some speculation back
and forth about like did Percy have a
role in writing it or is it all her and
I think it's pretty safe to say it's
probably all her
18:24 she moves to kentish town and in
London to be near Jane Williams it seems
they may have had some sort of dalliance
that could soured a bit when Jane
Williams reveals to Mary that Percy had
said that
you know he was less attracted to Mary
than he thought he was to Jane Williams
by 1826 Percy Florence becomes the legal
heir of the Shelley estate Mary is you
could say she's got more room to
maneuver she begins to assist friends
other people who are writing memoirs of
Percy so there's nothing that says that
she can't give other people information
she's just not supposed to do it here
itself and you know when she was editing
Percy's works which she did over the
course of her life she would she like
with his poetry she would put in all
sorts of information you know like you
to understand this poem you need to know
blah blah blah blah blah and so she's
revealing bits and piece this stuff but
its biography by doing so so pretty
pretty clever 1827 she helps some of her
friends obtain false passports while
she's visiting those friends in France
she contracts and gets over smallpox
which effectively destroys her looks
which you know in a way for a widow is
something that you could trade on but it
doesn't appear that she was particularly
interested in marrying she turned down
some offers at different different
points in time
from from other people the third edition
of Frankenstein comes out in 1831 by
this time she's also written the last
man and a number of other things
including the other short stories
she's churning out the short stories
during this time as well in order to be
able to make money to live on because
that was quite lucrative
whereas novel writing you know maybe
maybe it would be maybe it wouldn't it
depends on how the novel was reviewed
1832 her brother dies she began as
contributing pieces to what's called the
cabinet cyclopædia which is a number
of biographical entries published in
volumes I mean this is again kind of a
thing of the time you'd get people to
subscribe and that would give you the
capital to churn out these interesting
things and people would line their walls
so that is very very much a bourgeois
okay okay the kind of thing 1838 she's
actually paid to edit Shelley's poetical
works she travels in Europe with Percy
her son who never really amounted to
much you know it's that's another thing
we could talk about too I thought well
we'll sort of bring this to a close so
she gets a book out of that the history
of a six weeks tour 1851 she dies of a
suspected brain tumor and that's that's
the end there are some posthumously
published things as well and her she's
survived by her sister and by her and
her son and you know I was thinking
today as I was preparing for this
there's so many cases where we have
brilliant people who really get a lot
done in whatever whatever format
literary philosophical political you
know and usually their kids aren't
particularly gifted or ambitious or you
know I mean and then sometimes we don't
want them to be if you if you think
about like you know this may sound a
little mean but Christopher Tolkien
right
we don't want Christopher Tolkien to be
a great storyteller like his dad so he
could actually put together all the
notes because it requires a different
kind of thing you do want him to be a
zealous defender of the estate right
Frank Herbert's son I don't know the
verdict is canon
that would be you know so Mary Shelley
is clearly a brilliant and
underappreciated thinker her mother was
a brilliant thinker probably more
brilliant than her dad when I when you
look at the output and the influence so
she's had William Godwin wasn't a slouch
but he wasn't he wasn't a Mary
Wollstonecraft so either you've got one
case but then her son who you know she
brought up hey you know he's just kind
of you know does what he does is not
really that notable and it's kind of an
interesting thing to think about I mean
there are plenty of cases where there
are kids who do turn out to be great
from great parents but it usually
doesn't continue on very far you know
and and some people attribute them while
they're gonna be spoiled or they grow up
without facing the adversity I don't I
don't really think that's it
you know maybe so many different factors
have to come together just right in
order to make things things work you
know but neither of my kids want to be
philosophers you know I tried to like
get them interested in that sort of
thing they like talking about
philosophical stuff and either one's
attracted to the discipline yeah so yeah
I did want to talk a little bit about
some of these these these literary these
other literary things that she did so I
mentioned that she wrote short stories
and we're going to talk about mortal and
immortal as one of them I think I'd be a
great one to to hit on so she wrote
these short stories for what we're
called annuals and these were aimed at
mostly at middle class women they would
be bound in Nice silk bindings
gilt-edged pages and they you know they
needed good stories to fill out there
but nothing to nothing that would really
shake the
vote right and Mary Shelley said that so
she wrote this tool a hunt I write bad
articles which help to make me miserable
but I'm going to plunge into a novel and
hope that it's clear water will wash off
the mud of the magazine
so clearly she she didn't value that
that sort of work that she was doing it
was kind of just mercenary right that's
that's too bad because I think some of
those stories are quite good
she also you know she managed to publish
two different travel logs and one of
these was in 1817 called the six the
history of a six weeks tour her last
full-length book is the rambles in
Germany in Italy in 1840 1842 and 1843
and part of what she's doing there is
following out her her mother's own
example the Mary Wollstonecraft had
written letters written in Sweden Norway
and Denmark and that was what got
William Godwin to fall in love with her
so in a way and it's kind of interesting
that there's all of that connection
there but it also afforded her an
opportunity to like stick all sorts of
other stuff in there like all sorts of
reflections on the nature of human human
beings and social customs and you know
isn't it isn't it funny that these
people do things this way and you know
travel literature had been used in that
way for by the end time you know I think
about like Montesquieu and his Persian
letters or things along those lines you
can use literature you can use other
people's examples as ways to call your
own intuitive question she also wrote
you know a number of different
biographical entries and in them she
does the same sort of thing she's
interested in doing good history she's
also interested in reflection on the
meaning of these people so just a few of
the ones that that you know I think most
of us would recognize
that she wrote on Saturday would know
some of you these people myself that I
won't mention the ones I don't so she
wrote on Petrarch Boccaccio Pacino Pico
della Mirandola she's writing on these
Renaissance figures in Italy she wrote
on Cervantes in Machiavelli havedo and
commodes Montaigne Corneille Moliere
Pascal Racine fénelon Voltaire Rousseau
Madame Roland and Madame de Stahl all of
these you know then these are just a few
of the ones that she actually wrote for
that that cyclopædia and people I
haven't actually read any these people
have looked at them and said actually
these are really well researched well
thought out biography so you know maybe
she deserves to be recognized as a
writer less just as a novelist and more
in sort of a broader scope again sort of
like her mother you know Mary
Wollstonecraft wrote philosophical
treatises she also wrote novels that
kind of you know follow along those
lines sure a travelogue she wrote sure
on all sorts of other interesting things
as well so the the only other thing I
wanted to bring up in terms of biography
and literary stuff was the last man so I
went I looked at some of the the reviews
of this and it did not come it did not
come out well
reviewers didn't like the theme of
lastness which had become kind of a
common thing apparently by that time
individual reviewers said that the book
had stupid cruelties in it they said
they're basically his name
you know but I I thought it's just dull
unfortunately if you know you read it
good right what was your impression yeah
it's it's a it's a slow getting into I
kept thinking of the master of
Ballantrae okay I was like I'm comparing
it to that which you know is that Robert
Lewis Stevenson like his final work and
that thing is just crazy because it's
you know it's kind of the height of both
his adventure along with him and him
doing kind of a ghost of the mystical oh
yeah there's really a psychological
drama and so I like reading this when I
was like oh it's kind of bad but wanting
there's so much drama in it right that's
what I mean is like I feel like so I so
I kept thinking is like oh like he's
trying to get this other guy you're
about to have like that sort of tension
and it resolves really fast and you end
up not having any of those aspects that
you kind of expected to really yeah then
the tensions are just kind of not built
in the same way and not resolved in the
same way it almost feels picaresque
right where are the things that are
happening there's no inherent need for
them to go the way that they do yeah but
in a picaresque novel you expect more of
it apparently it's it's what they call a
god winning enough and I don't know that
much about that genre because I'm not a
reader of God one other than
philosophical stuff I don't know have
you read any of as ill the immortal
immortal is also is there to be cut when
you dance interesting I wonder why
that's the case
no no why no I just remember that's
something that I saw as like ah like I
like glanced at it and they're like oh
it's in the gun when you install a so
wasn't well liked later let's really as
it as a short story yeah that's
interesting cuz it's probably one of her
best games - interesting one so let's
let's talk about that one first I mean
the theme is
the thought the thing I found most
interesting about I wish we should say
for the people who are watching this you
got a guy who is working for an
alchemist he's in love with a woman
she's kind of a you know kind of shrew
in many ways and throws him over for
another guy and he is the alchemist is
trying to make an event elixir of
immortality and it I actually I really
liked the description about like how
it's gonna be rose-colored and then
it'll have Sparks and golden sparks and
stuff like that and the alchemist tells
them making you watch and then if it
turns color you wake me up and all that
and but it tells the guy this'll this'll
because the guy says well what are we
doing this for well this is this will
cure love you don't want to cure your
love for this I forget the name of the
girl but and it turns out the guy does
want to cure love so he takes any drinks
half of it and then it you know it's
dashed and the alchemist
oh you've destroyed by my work you know
and you know it turns out to be very
nerve aiding and in a way and he goes
and he he tells the girl what's what and
she you know she responds to this new
firmness on his part of vitality and
they get married and then it turns out
that he's half immortal and it you know
it's I don't know if there's much other
literature on that that sort of
problematic of the immortal who has to
see everybody disappeared dying yeah
yeah that prior to that I mean there's
the reference of story The Wandering Jew
okay and there is a story about a guy in
ancient Greece who's given eternal life
but they don't give an eternal youth
which is almost like the opposite of it
he goes senile and he has transformed
into a grass
hopper or a cicada or something like
that and his wife you know doesn't like
it and and you know wants him to be old
like her and he can't ever know sort of
leaves off you know yeah but it's but
it's an interesting idea how how do you
know cuz he finds gray hairs how do you
know what half of eternity would be yeah
that's what I thought was the most
interesting part of that right you know
whatever length of time is supposed to
be eternity he gets he gets half of it
dang he keeps wondering like you know
when does this end and yeah it's yeah
it's kind of a fascinating story cuz he
also use like well I can't commit
suicide but also like no one seems to be
killing me yeah all these tensions that
got want to die but I'm not gonna do
this and this other thing is he owns up
with these kind of conundrums of saying
well how do I is like I can't hear
anyone else I can't do love yeah because
they wouldn't be fair yeah II saw her
age deplorable
yeah you know and he doesn't do what
immortals are you know immortals saved
by getting killed do it in all sorts of
other science fiction and fantasy stuff
is like go fight wars get you know gain
power like you know Roger Zelazny 's and
burr novels right these people screw
around all the time
literally they screw a whole bunch of
non immortals and cider kids and then
they get in Wars and build kingdoms and
fight each other and stuff like that and
the Kane novels you know similar sort of
situation you know he's gloomy but that
doesn't prevent him from taking
positions as generals or admirals or
things like that and whatever like a
spiders you know giant spiders gonna eat
him and kill him suddenly he discovers
that he wants to live you know there's
nothing nothing like that in this one
yes yeah he's just kind of meandering
along yeah he has an accumulated wealth
and power and yeah you think that he
might well given his prior history you
understand why he doesn't because he's
kind of this meat guy who only took a
job in the first place because the girl
was throwing him over and you know he's
got he's got kind of like it doesn't it
doesn't become any more intellectually
gifted though right doesn't like go I
mean if you or I were given that sort of
thing we'd be like well guess we're
gonna be spending a lot of time in the
library you know now I don't have to
like prioritize among books because I
got enough time to read them all yeah he
doesn't do that at all no and he wasn't
alchemists assistant so you think oh
he's gonna make new mess him self you
know why not you know even email commits
and he doesn't do that either it's
fascinating and he just basically spends
a lot of time saying how could I end
this you know the last man - he's the
last human being in the world what's he
gonna do he's got a dog and that's about
it there's I guess without other without
other people that you can relate to it's
not just that other people existing in
the world other people that you can
relate to maybe life ISM life ISM it's
worth living in the sense of you can't
kill yourself but it's not it's not
valuable life yeah you know yeah so yeah
that's kind of an interesting point well
let's talk about some of the key
philosophical themes so you know
everybody's take on Frankenstein always
focuses on the fact that you know you
create a life now you know what's going
to happen
yeah there's a lot of teks on
Frankenstein where technology it's it's
bad because look it created a new kind
of being and look how miserable it made
everybody and I guess in this story
that's that's true but it doesn't have
to be that way you know and I kind of
like the idea of thinking about the you
know the creature sees him as a father
father and mother and Frankenstein is a
terrible father and mother to the
creature he doesn't take care of its
education he doesn't love it in any way
he betrays it when he's what he's made a
pact with it maybe when we do create you
know so I mean here's this is you just
kind of turning the thing that it's had
as people read this and they they talk
about oh you know we've got to be
careful about creating a Frankenstein
monster well maybe we don't create
Frankenstein monsters if we actually
treat the things that we create the
right way so you know that what are the
what are the prospects for us we we may
be able to create new human life it
probably won't be us because we have
some ethical you know restrictions in
place that are doing that but it's going
to happen somewhere else in the world
the Chinese will do it or you know some
some other technologically advanced
civilization with less ethical
restrictions or more secrecy will will
certainly do it so that's one
possibility
creating creating new human beings of
some sort then there's the whole like
well what are we doing with AI robots
computer networks all of that sort of
stuff
maybe those are life maybe those are
intellect eventually I mean Syria was
just exploring with Andy the other day
and Syria is still pretty stupid mm-hmm
even more stupid on the iPhone 10 with
the current operating system than Siri
seemed to be just a couple of years ago
when I played around with it there
seemed to be more things that Siri just
can't process so you don't but
eventually then I've been with
autocomplete on my Android you know and
it goes back and now changes my sentence
at the beginning oh yeah when I come
back I'm like there's a typo I'm like oh
you changed it after every R in the
sentence you have to reread the whole
thing no that's interesting that
autocorrect the total side note but
autocorrect is less useful the more
intelligent of a writer you are right
because it's going to get more and more
wrong with the stuff where like you're
breaking a rule but you know why you're
breaking the rule right yeah or you do
want the longer word you know yeah yeah
but I mean I love the lines of that I
remembered someone noting is a you know
he's a tech consultant he was noting
that there were some robots and Cameron
Murphy was the boss in robotics or than
a different one but people were kicking
the robots oh yeah yeah yeah and there's
a lot on Twitter
cuz that were useful yeah yeah because
on Twitter people are gonna want to be
teaching the robots as violence this is
well this is this is how you get Skynet
or anything this was the the caption do
you remember what the the reason why
they were doing it was no oh okay
so it gets it gets more interesting
there actually looked bad from the
outside the optics as people say are bad
because you're you're like abusing the
robot knocking stuff out of its hands
which must be frustrating it right
they're actually trying to get it to
learn how to adjust to its environment I
wasn't sure if a some of them were
actually the people working on it yeah
yeah now of course they'll probably be
some sadist who act
really does do stuff like that just to
screw with their their robot and you
know if you think about like where we're
going one of the biggest days of course
of a I you know because look at where
everything else is gone with with
technology the internet it's gonna be
sex robots oh yeah right because you can
think about like how video technology
progressed well it was so people could
you know shoot each other having sex at
home yeah but yeah then the internet so
many of the sites are or that so it's
inevitable that that that's going to be
happening and if they do achieve if they
are brought to some level of
intelligence there are going to be some
people doing some pretty terrible stuff
to them you know and you know maybe
they'll talk with each other you know
maybe they again we go back to the thing
if you don't want to Frankenstein's
monster maybe treat the things that
you're creating his new life better you
know give them some reasons to think
that we regular humans shouldn't be
snuffed out yeah yeah yeah I don't know
what do you think is that theme of like
the can be so careful you know in
creating artificial life so I've been
hashed out to death or yeah I mean I
think it's I think it's available in the
text but I think yeah that's one one of
the nice things about novels is not
trying to make that explicit argument
yeah you know it's right people have
drawn that all through criticism they're
billing this is the main point of it
yeah and I mean again it's late into the
text it's available certainly but I
wouldn't say that it you know doesn't
have to be the theme isn't the theme
the thing that we take from it yeah you
know I not that offer intent is that
Dolan be Allah but is that even you know
in effect which she had accepted you
know because sometimes you'll hear is
even being this response to you know
falling in line with the pastoral sort
of poets and that sort of thing and this
you know it's you know it's like oh did
you buy that the reading of it no I mean
it's it's certainly and some of that is
I mean what was the inciting occasion
okay yeah and it's a group of people
together telling ghost stories so it's
got to be a story where something goes
goes tragically wrong yeah how is this a
ghost story
well event which is actually an
interesting the budget I mean it's not
really even a supernatural story because
everything that's happening and it is
supposed to be happening in accordance
with the science of the time right which
of course it's not but yeah I mean it's
very much an in science fiction in that
sense yeah a supernatural horror story
or something like that because now you
have a no not but this alongside of you
know just like Poe's stuff or any of
those things where well Poe does have a
few very science II yeah things like a
case of is it the case of Monsieur
Valdemar the one where they they've got
a dead guy and they're using galvanism
to keep to like bring him back from the
very edge of death and get him to talk
to them hey then then of course it's
terrible you know it's like
be dead and he just wants to be like
what led to die but I think is it's the
same sort of thing they're fascinated
with galvanism mmm-hmm you know it's
capacity to bring things back to life
apparently the original modern
prometheus the the first use of that was
about Benjamin Franklin is his
experiments of electricity oh well yeah
kind of kind of an interesting idea you
know the other thing that does come up
is this fear about and this is something
that we have in our own time fear about
a new stronger race being developed by
us and then being able to reproduce so
if it's just one Frankenstein monster
that's cool you know he's gonna do crazy
stuff and you know be afraid of fire and
you know hurt a little girl or things
like that and then maybe kill a polar
bear down the line
but if he can reproduce then all bets
are off for Humanity right so we have a
similar worry about technology when it
comes to we don't want AI to be able to
reproduce itself
that's you know that then could we have
no way of controlling it after that and
then you know we have we have science
fictiony things too about like creating
artificial human beings would be better
than us in some ways like they they
would be physically stronger mentally
more intelligence you know less
restrained by psychological hang-ups and
then they'd replace us right that's the
great fear so yeah I think that's that's
a theme that is definitely running
through here because why why is it is it
just he's giving a big screw you to the
monster when he destroys the corpse
bride or his busy
really worried about the future of
humanity
what do you think yeah I mean it's it's
a commissioner there there's that whole
theme of of anger coming into play right
and then and then then making these
weird decisions cuz like they kind of
resolve or get along and then a
character it gets its upset or decides
to anger the other character in some way
and then and then we're off again yeah
which I'm like in the last man where it
kind of you know unfolds like in this
one you actually do and it's kind of
interesting that you have it from both
Frankenstein and his monster they're
both very human in that sense yeah okay
and you get the idea that that wolf
stone crap I mean she's just writing
this a pretty young so and at an age
where she's seeing a lot of anger in the
household and its effects anger happens
because we take offence at something
either it is the way that we think it is
somebody's actually trying to screw with
us or put us down in some way or we just
perceive it and we then were off to the
races and then you know we we could get
over it or we could just hold on to it
and it's rare that any of the characters
ever at the opportunities that have get
over it
and so it produces this wedge that that
just simply can't be overcome and I you
know I thought down the line you know I
do all this work on on anger I thought
it'd be very interesting just a duo go
through this this just as one text and
look at every single instance of
referencing anger rage annoyance you
know that whole modality and sort of
plot out how important it is and what
what Shelley has to say about it
in the text through through the the
mouths of the characters yeah you know
never talking about now I almost makes
me you know wondering again latent not
necessarily there but but possible in
the text if in part whether again she's
doing it explicitly or just like you
know intentionally it happens but
there's some exploration of that idea of
parentage and like children like those
yeah like and again not just like that
they're always a mystic for that sense
of what is it between parent and child
when they're in disagreement and
obviously Frankenstein does not walk
this child which is another you know
thing and you name it like it's like oh
and then what that has to do with those
interactions of a child who feels
unwanted and how that anchor kind of
inter plays yeah and that's I mean that
is a theme that could run I mean there's
so many people that can relate to that
even if it's not just that like you know
oh it was totally unwanted and totally
rejected by mom and dad
it could be well you know turns out that
after a lot of soul-searching and
thinking about it I'm gay you know and
mom and dad can't accept that then you
know you're out you know what do we do
with the family you know gatherings for
Christmas do we talk about this or not
or it could be it could be being
rejected just for having the wrong sort
of temperaments or you know a lot of
times there's there's people who just
they seem like they just can't relate to
each other you see it from the outside
you're like what that was wrong with you
you know can't you see that he's trying
to say this and he's trying to say this
but they somehow they just can't put it
together yeah and that children do want
to be logged and
have a safe family environment I mean if
you look at the Godwin's you know they
they really they didn't provide right
particularly good household for for
these kids so yeah not that not that
Mary and Percy Shelley's had Heath yeah
so that you know I think that's
something that's that's very relatable
just like you know with the Odyssey is a
little bit of a digression but you know
I started thinking about this as I was
listening to it on CD back in my early
40s the first first three or four books
are all basically Telemachus and his
story and you know you think after all
the you know tell me amused blah blah
blah and the gods doing this and that
but it's all about Telemachus and he's
got to deal with these jerks who are
trying to marry his mom because his dad
is off maybe dead hoping his dad and
come back and he's now of age where he's
got he's got a city like put his foot
down and he not only you know not only
does he have to do that but he also
wants to do it he hates these guys guts
and you know when I was when I was
listening to it I was thinking wow you
know I could totally relate to this as
18 year old Greg mm-hmm you know my mom
dating guys that I didn't like I mean
they weren't trying to take over our
house or no yes or applauding to kill me
but you know that that the absent father
and now I've got to figure out what to
do on my own and you know I don't have
anyone I can rely on
I mean Telemachus gets Athena right and
get some advice from from Menelaus and
Nestor but there are these these themes
that are you know very relatable in
terms of what we could call family
dynamics social dynamics what else oh
you know is this it gets framed as a
gothic novel it gets framed as a
romantic novel are those are those good
descriptors for it isn't romantic
I mean there's certainly some some
themes about the individual and you know
it's you have a you know sort of
romantic hero figure larger-than-life
doing something against the norm you
know there's a lot of parent I mean the
Paradise Lost is referenced by the
monster himself but I think there's also
a lot of sort of imitation of Paradise
Lost in the structure of the work itself
but you know we we often I mean I guess
there's different kinds of Romanticism
right there's the romanticism of like
you said the pastoralist
let's return in nature those mechanisms
and wheels and cogs they're bad you know
tearing up the earth
don't use galvanism but keep the
electricity up in the clouds this isn't
like that it's not as if she's she's
rejecting all but technologic
progress and possibilities and there's
that you know there's this there's this
fascination with creation of life a lot
of the romantic stuff also has to do
with like defending your own right right
so I guess you could say it's it's it's
a romantic novel but it's not an
optimistic romantic that one no you know
the last man is more optimistic in some
ways that Frankenstein is because these
people have conflicts but they get over
them
and then you know what what brings them
down plague and you know accidents of
life stuff like that you're able to get
through the the issues more easily I
think yeah what were you gonna say
[Music]
oh I just saying you know in terms of it
you know the Frank is and the Gothic you
sense of it I was trying to think of
other whoa similar ones yeah you know
this is something that I was thinking
about as well bye
so this becomes part of film adaptation
right so does Dracula but those are
written a long distance apart from each
other in time and yet we have this kind
of horror slash Victorian which we call
it like stable or catalog of like stock
characters right Frankenstein
Frankenstein's monster of course Dracula
the Wolfman dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde what
else gets added into that sort of famous
monster types that can easily be put on
the screen because they're all
anthropomorphic right you know I mean
they have the you know Dorian Gray
becomes kind of a character and that
that sort of thing although I think
that's later Invisible Man
yeah it's gets and after a while like
the the the fact that some of these are
very far apart from each other in time
really from radically different
generations in in yeah the film stuff if
they could they may as well all be from
the same era right by our time you know
see you could have something like the
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen being
being put together as a movie drawing
and quite a few those figures or or you
think back to like Laurel and Hardy
right could be there's Laurel and Hardy
and the Wolfman Laurel Hardy and
Frankenstein The Mummy that was another
right and so you get a whole bunch of
that you can even think of it in terms
of those cereals right
we had Franken berry and Count Chocula
and fruit brute that was the werewolf
right by the time that it can be
commodified like that all of these have
become part of a like a collective yeah
of ministers of the month the Mummy's
history be interesting how much of that
would be you know actually even early
20th century with the opening of some of
the tombs yeah you know how much that
was based on ideas of those curses from
opening them versus I don't know Speer
the latest stuff right because I've been
stalker is 1890s 1900s and we a me I
mean with and actually with Polidori we
really have I mean a vampire tale
coinciding with which I mean that one's
kind of funny because excellent sides
with Frankenstein a funny thing about
Paulo Tori's tales people thought Byron
always wrote it ok and now people think
that Polidori wrote it with byron being
the vampire her there's there's there's
a fair bit of evidence attempt a okay be
the case which is pretty funny so I mean
we do this like it's not like vampire
stories weren't around before right but
Stoker I mean takes it to that next
level Buffy Polidori yeah gives a
significant one or really draft yeah I
still have my mom used to have to be
kind of later yeah
when Lovecraft has some Egyptian stuff
in there but I gotta he's 20s and 30s
well 10 is twenties thirties so yeah
you know that'd be fascinating yeah I
thought you know it it's almost
impossible to talk about Frankenstein I
think without talking about the
adaptations the other theme that I
wanted to hit on that I call the
imperfect imperfection of the
perfectible though the romantics were
even though they're rejecting a good bit
of the Enlightenment the one thing that
most of them did accept was the perfect
ability of humankind that you know we
could we could make progress and not
only as individuals but as society we
get better and better and better by
stages at Mary Wollstonecraft actually
said listen you never actually can even
have like really good relations between
men and women until you fix things in
society except for some very rare
exceptions and even then you may have
tragic cases so let's let's work on
fixing the society and I think
Frankenstein and you know some of the
stories and even the last man there's
always imperfections in whatever is
being perfected
there's always fall through so you don't
get a story of a steady incline instead
there's there's a incline of then
there's a fall then there's maybe some
troughs are there and then a go fall
even even further you know yeah well
you're the immortality you know what I
think is a great thing so you've got it
now what the hell are you gonna do with
it yeah that's a good point yeah that
the immortality would be a perfection
and in a sense of you've brought
something to its complete fulfillment
yeah that's that that's actually another
theme that goes beyond Mary Shelley and
is her classic theme what do you do when
you actually get what you want you know
let's say you actually could have not
just immortality but like super
heightened dental
would that actually lead you to being
happy or would that make you less happy
because now you actually understand that
the universe doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anything you know that you know you
realize just how much you'll never
actually be able to know even with being
immortal and in completion you get the
Midas touch that doesn't man well I mean
I mean you have a similar Solomon asking
if Solomon asked for wisdom right and a
nice toe I mean it the writings that are
attributed to him vanity and even even
as even his own life I mean yeah yeah
they used some wisdom early on and then
he kind of screwed up the nation he was
in charge of the other lyric prosperous
right powerful you know and then his son
screwed it up after him you know
raha BOM loses the ten northern kingdoms
you know essentially telling him that
he's gonna be tougher on him that his
dad was not a smart move I was just I
was just remembering a Rick and Morty
thing actually where early on Rick was
talking about school and he says he has
nothing it's not for smart people you
know this is something actually I think
a lot of people go through when they go
off to college and they encounter these
people especially if they come from a
family background where like so they're
first-generation college and they think
academics are supposed to like have it
together and be intelligent and all that
and you you engage with these people and
some of them really are at least at the
time that you're you're encountering
them and then the rest of you you're
like what the hell is wrong with these
people you know they you know they're
saying this I know this is wrong you
know or I see through the the story that
they're telling already
maybe I'd be better off just you know
reading on my own so getting everything
that you want doesn't always produce
grainy happiness the other thing too is
if you're really intelligent you might
you might look at all the different
things that we offer people in our
society and be like that's not actually
that good you know you can sort of see
through see through things so I don't
know maybe maybe that wouldn't make us
happy there's always some sort of
imperfection that only emerges when we
when we move to the next stage I mean
like Frankenstein he doesn't think about
what's gonna happen with this monster he
doesn't even think I'm creating a
monster right what's gonna happen when I
create this thing he doesn't know it's
not gonna haunt my footsteps know kill
all my family yeah destroy my life I
guess the last thing we should talk
about too is because they're gonna kick
us out before too long so the narrative
structure right story within a story
with a story I actually like that myself
I think it's kind of a good storytelling
technique for this somebody I remember
some critic complained that each of the
narrator's talks to similarly to each
other I don't know that I see that it's
as a terrible flaw myself
I mean it's if you look at enough even
like travel in or adventure literature
that time period yeah I mean historical
distance it actually seems very similar
present-day yeah but if you think of
yeah genre how different would they be
if their terms of narrative yes in terms
of
because it's like these are the
stylistic moves that we make yeah I mean
they are different so the story within
the story that you get you got the
captain first right and he he tells the
story about finding this guy this crazy
guy who has this wild story and that's
Frankenstein himself and then
Frankenstein's monster gets a story
dropped within there as well it seems to
me like the three narratives the the
diction is the same but the the motives
I have characters telling the story are
very different and the first part of it
the framing part is well I don't know if
this guy's actually telling you know I
don't know if everything he's saying is
true or not you know but here's what he
said and then you get you know we get
further into it you know and for me it's
almost like you know it he said he said
so it's still from the first narrators
voice you can always take it that way or
it's them doing the other person's story
but then it's still going to have
something of their own style yeah so
yeah I mean I've never found that but it
is a it is a fun structure yeah I kind
of always enjoyed that ass but you have
to get into it certainly it's actually
somewhat of a sidebar but a freshman in
high school and will be getting into
Mary Shelley later and having to write
now work through some shorter stories of
okay that era just to get her used to
accuse oh and with the the different
narrators in treasure and that sort of
thing so we've done like two Lord
Dunsany works and then his stuffs dry
interesting but dry yeah and then a few
others it's kind of funny because she's
like oh I really like that story I was
like oh no one was
drei yeah you know there's so much
there's so much preoccupation even
running all the way into the early 20th
century with social niceties and
narrating narrating those sorts of
things that I think a lot of our our
younger readers just they're you know
they don't know what that stuff is about
yeah I mean the Y Asiana is a relatively
newer thing and that's what we put you
know a lot of their reading time and
energy and so it's true coming into
these other other pieces yeah it's a
little bit of a shift I mean even even
within certain fantasy like Y fantasy
old maid stuff the one like Newberry
metals in the 80s and I'm thinking of
the hair on the crown and which actually
the blue sword is a prequel to it okay
another thing I know that there's a
prequel won and it was like an honor and
then the other one and the kids can't
read it
really yeah I mean they're just like
because it reminded me it's similar even
like Lois will be a grind for a lot of
students and it's just fascinating to me
that again nothing I can't read it but
it actually takes more effort than some
of the ones with it requires so sort of
not apprenticeship but yeah sort of well
it starts off introspective and it's
light and then they even has a flashback
within a flashback we can wait which if
you're used to that I got this is like
nothing here's know if I whereas the
action is yeah you know keeping track of
narrative structures like how deep are
you going in that that is a skill you
know another skillet oh yeah no this is
totally off topic but when I'm when I'm
teaching philosophy texts if it's like
so let's say platonic dialogues or
Aristotle and his approach to things you
know doing things very dialectically or
say Rene Descartes
posing things and then you know saying
no no that's not the case or if David
Hume setting up opponents arguments to
demolish them about everything in
between it's it's really difficult for
them and I don't know this is a
generation thing if it's gotten worse
over time because I think I know this
was a problem when I first started
teaching students twenty years ago and I
think it was also a problem sometimes
for some of my own fellow grad students
they couldn't keep track of when an
author was putting forth a position as
somebody else's position and when the
author is putting forth the position as
their own position when they're putting
forth a position or to attack it or
critique it and when they're actually
endorsing it yeah you know because
there's plenty of times where Socrates
says so what you're saying is blah blah
blah blah blah and he's not saying that
because he's you know going to agree
with that he's gonna he's gonna back it
down in just a minute
yeah though he's the worst for that one
okay well you know other other people's
were thing to be kind of difficult
Nietzsche for example Nietzsche is
constantly referencing other people's
things sometimes quite obliquely and
it's understandable that students are
like what the hell is this soup in front
of me what are the points that what
what's he actually saying you know
because not everybody won't develop
things in it here's axiom one here's
axiom two now that leads to this you
know it's pretty rare in any sort of
intellectual
yeah you know so yeah yeah it's kind of
an interesting worry so if if if we
don't I mean it's one thing we can teach
individual students or we can teach an
elite how to read this sort of
literature productively right but if
we're not doing that on a broad base
yeah what are you doing
what sort of prospects is are there for
whatever it is that were we're trying to
continue on you know when reading has
always been a minority occupation even
an even at the time when when things
like this were quite popular yeah yeah
how should we how should we view that
sort of thing what's your take I mean
you're you're deep in the heart of this
yourself
yeah it's problematic I mean you use
some of the tools of understanding oh
yeah some of the tools of understanding
like how do we one of the the themes
that are available within Mary Shelley
allow you to talk about the present day
while going back into fantastical and
historical past yeah it gives it gives
you more anchor points and I mean
certainly you can have them present day
but we have to make certain that we have
some of them yeah
and not just just just as the latest in
Greece which isn't a theme that she's
getting at Malik and finding dystopian
and it's still being literature in the
20th century more the other day or you
and then I'm chasing your own tail and
you know as Neil postman eventually gets
to it ends up being trivia and you know
I think that that that can be a thing
and we don't want Mary Shelley they
become triviai there may certainly get
Cliff Notes version of her it's like
here's the thing yeah yeah or you know
the Wikipedia breakdown or but I think I
think that we have questions of how do
we bring that back I mean you know in
terms of philosophy in terms of
literature making certain that were
still grappling with these ideas because
we can say oh we figured out all the
stuff that Mary Shelley has presented
but we haven't and each generation kind
of you know will discover her texts anew
to a degree which is part of reason
she's still right it's interesting if if
the current generation well not the
current the if the the generation who
are kids right now and just entering
college right now what we call
generations II have a genuine prospect
in their lifetime of you know if not
true artificial intelligence certainly
incredibly sophisticated algorithms
programs hardware you know that works
things like that that certainly could
approximate or imitate intelligence and
in very sophisticated ways this can be
an analog for it but there's a lot of
mapping that
to take place yeah right yeah because
they're not working with meat machines
of song together corpses and galvanism
or anything like that so there's a lot
of translation that would have to take
place right absolutely so I guess one of
the questions I'd ask is how did it how
do you see it's one thing to say oh yeah
it's dealing with the same theme and do
so at a very general level but that
doesn't get them to the point to be able
to think constructively and critically
about that it's sort of like the
intermediate level where the real action
happens yeah so how do we do that
how do we get them to how do we promote
that uh to someone related to that and
we were talking about it before we
started with Alistair McIntyre where you
were mentioning he talked about dilemma
he said yeah one of the ways he resolves
dilemmas is to go say well how did we
get here you know that's not the future
okay okay I got here you know from this
pathway and not that this is we use the
pathway but as as that past anchor you
know allowing for that and saying we can
have this thought that back here yeah
because there's this space and I've seen
it a few times in doing nonfiction
pieces you know that are contemporary
were then they point back and like
there's once remember it's called the
algorithmic self and so giving them that
as an initial fodder yeah and then when
they get into this so this is kind of
cultural literacy basis for that but
then that raises the question in order
to have cultural literacy do you really
need to read the book the whole book and
have read through it several times and
thought about it or can you rely on the
Cliff Notes version that gives you
you know as this people the gist yeah or
the bullet points or I mean for this one
because it's been translated into film
Iasi not familiar with the films of it I
can think well so like a trope now yes
yeah because the original Dracula the
which wasn't called Dracula Nosferatu
yeah yeah I mean that one you you
actually get quite a bit yeah and so
that's pretty close to the story
yeah right that the Frankenstein's
Frankenstein's monster in film and TV
adaptations very quickly becomes
dissociated from Frankenstein itself
that's part of why I call it I think
that's right yeah and becomes just this
scary
meat thing yeah I think the the amount
of internal wrestling gets lost with
that yeah I mean like it's sort of in
penny dreadful you wish which used it
recently and there's also a Frankenstein
recent two that had shown being in it
the monster does like talk about how my
life socks you know why did you meet
make me and all that sort of so you get
that yeah there's no there's no
necessity of it you can just have you
know the guy with the bowl to fall down
on magnets yeah stuff like that
running around chasing Abbott Costello
yeah so a scooby-doo yeah since it yeah
it's interesting I mean I wonder if if
there is a way to translate it around
into a different medium that it would
work well in but I think it is an
interesting one and part of it is that
written form of working your brain
through it and I think there are six
that as your brain works through them
they work on you as Shakespeare's like
that yeah
these stories aren't that interesting
you copy two other stories at the time
like this the actual words yeah
and that seemed like to know if your
Shakespeare you've lost the whole moment
yeah there's arguments being made of
Shakespeare quite often there's there's
there's arguments being made here maybe
to a lesser extent maybe maybe there's
more like expostulations sure know
yourself a bit there's you never have
them say that but yeah that should
wretched creature I imagine that there
would be ways that you could do it other
than this then this particular piece but
I think this piece is a very good one
for that I guess would be you know
there's another thing too that that kind
of speaks for it so it gets taught a lot
in high schools right I think still yeah
so it provides us with at least a common
basis or we can say listen you've all
read Frankenstein right do you remember
this and that so maybe that maybe that
recommends it and then helps to keep it
in in circulation over and over again
anyway we better we better bring this
kind of close so thanks very much for a
good conversation and yeah so nice
kickoff to the year and one book to
recommend one book to recommend if
you're
really really into dry stuff
[Music]
you